safety is what anna palescho is
searching for she's just stepped into
poland after fleeing the city of patova
she's traveled by train bus and foot for
days with her eight and 11 year old son
and daughter they're out of danger for
now still she has little idea where
they'll go from here
hope to england
hope we have friends from church
and they invited us and they we will
stay in their houses and hope you will
get visas and
be safe there
honest stories like thousands who've
also fled from ukraine this border
crossing in madika poland is in chaos
it's a haphazard tent city made up of a
patchwork of international non-profit
groups aid workers and private
individuals who've arrived in poland
from all over the globe yeah they're not
representing the country they are
spreading the humanity
because they are human that's why
they're here
what greets these exhausted refugees is
a cluttered and confused group of mostly
well-meaning individuals their donated
aid is practical and sometimes indulgent
but there's little coordination
one of the big reasons that poland has
absorbed the majority of refugees coming
from ukraine isn't just because of its
proximity it's also because of the
refugees necessity
many are coming by foot and up until now
this has been the only pedestrian
crossing
from the border trusting refugees pile
into buses that take them five
kilometers away to an abandoned
distribution warehouse
children are often alone as their
confused parents search for help but
even the volunteers aren't sure who's
running the relief operation
looks like people they want to help but
they don't know how to help we don't
know what to do it's like no techniques
no plan
it's like
a little bit chaotic chaotic a lot
local authorities admit no one is
checking to see those showing up are who
they say they are
and they say
it's not their responsibility to check
this is just a reception center this
region is only temporary only a few
people stay here and they are leaving
that leaves refugees to wander
assembling a plan
most have given little thought to their
next chapter and soon discover they've
fled an immediate threat in ukraine
only to encounter a new one
kimberly hellcat al jazeera medica
poland